[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to tonight's
episode of beginner breakdown my name is
always it's Alex mollering I'm excited
to be talking with you about our topic
tonight uh quick shout out to everyone
in the chat already from Egypt from
Brazil so excited to have you all here
um tonight our topic is basic checkmates
we'll move a little beyond the pure
basic ones but these are kind of our
bread and butter and I realized I don't
think I've ever done a dedicated episode
to this topic but it's so so important
um
and so we're going to get started with
one of the most I think fundamental of
these kind of basic introductory
checkmates and that's the latter
checkmate
so the basic idea here is we have two
pieces that can attack in a straight
line whether it's two Rooks or the uh
two queens or a queen in a rook
um the not usually the Bishops the
Bishops controlling the diagonals the
ladder doesn't work with that exactly
because there's always gaps so we'll
talk about the two Bishops later but
with the pieces like the queen and the
Rooks we can do What's called the latter
pattern and essentially we're going to
build rungs one at a time to construct a
ladder forcing our opponent to an edge
of the board
something really Critical with any
Checkmate idea basically in the whole
game but especially in these end game
ones with very few pieces on the board
is you want to force your opponent's
king towards the edge
why is that well it's because we need to
eliminate the number of squares that the
king can escape to right whenever
someone's in check the three things you
do to determine whether it's a check or
a Checkmate are to say can the king move
out of the way can you block the attack
or can you remove the attacking piece by
capturing it
well in an end game like this where your
opponent has no pieces there is no way
to block a check or remove the attacker
unless it's close like in this case this
doesn't work because I can take it
but we can escape to a bunch of squares
and a king just in the center on its own
is normally going to have eight
different squares it can run to
right one in every direction
if we get a king to an edge of the board
so just let's just move back and forth
and force this King to walk to the edge
you'll notice that already here the king
is already now Limited to Simply five
rather than those eight right we've lost
one whole row in this case a rank of
options and if we continue all the way
to a corner the number decreases even
more right now the king only has three
places to go as opposed to the five on
the edge and then the eight in the
center
and the fewer spaces the King has the
easier it will be for us to take away
all the remaining ones and call a
checkmate
so with that in mind trying to force our
opponent towards an edge or possibly a
corner the ladder mate goes like this
first we're going to position our pieces
on edges in this case I'm going to put
my queen somewhere where she can defend
the Rook from behind
so there's hundreds of ways you could do
this Checkmate but I'm just going to
very simply maneuver my pieces into
position so something like Queen E2 say
the king moves and I'll put my queen on
the edge and notice now it's defending
my Rook so my rook's always going to be
safe
and I'm preparing the ladder pattern
we have two rungs already on the ladder
and the one we care about is the one
that is preventing the king from moving
right so in this case I am looking to
push the king up to the eighth rank
uh so the King has to move
I need to look and say which two rungs
are my pieces controlling well the queen
is controlling the second rank which the
king can't get to normally it that'd be
two moves not one
but the Rook is controlling the third if
it wasn't there the king could move down
away from this Edge
so
I leave The Rook because it needs to
keep control of this rung and I move the
queen up to control the next one
now the king is forced back again
and with this ladder set up it's going
to be easy to get lost in this Rhythm
just keep moving one at a time back and
forth all the way until again notice how
we've taken away an option the king
can't move farther back anymore so the
next time we go up it's Checkmate we've
taken away all of these possible squares
but what we need to remember is not so
much the rhythm of the back and forth
but more the idea that this King always
exists on three ranks and files
there are three ranks and three files
and moving it to an edge or a corner
slices some of those off
and we can control the other two with
our Queen and or Rook
um one thing to note is
I like the move Queen to A2 here better
than you know if we had some setup of
getting the queen out in front right
something like this is not as good
because even though we can keep the
setup going
Our Queen being in front is not super
helpful
because she's not defended by The Rook
in the same way that she would defend
the Rook
so she's going to get captured so it's
just a little safer if you put the queen
in the back where even if the king gets
close enough to attack The Rook it
doesn't make a difference because it's
defended
one final note is this is uh some people
will look at this and say there's a
theoretical best way to do it and I've
actually taken
um I think there's two or three that are
all the same down to mate in a table
base
but if we take a look one of those
options was kind of a perfect Computer
Solution
Queen to B5
King F2
King G4
Rook H3 sacrificing The Rook because if
you take it
it's Checkmate on H5 and if you don't
take it it's Checkmate here because the
king covers these three
this is
silly right technically it's the best
but I much prefer the philosophy of No
Stress Chess it's kind of my own
personal system which is if you can do
something perfectly in chess and get a
Checkmate two moves faster than me
that's awesome I'm really glad you
calculated that perfectly and
efficiently
but it's much more practical to
understand the basic idea for why you're
doing your moves and find a simple way
that's always going to work that you can
just use without having to think too
hard because it's going to make your
calculations a lot more efficient and
you're going to save time where it
matters in the end
okay
so now let's do a quick practice round
feel free in the chat or in person to
suggest moves here but it's white to
move and we are going to try and set up
a laddermate against this King
so we have a lot of different options
here I would recommend first pick which
wall you know you want to push the king
towards because that's going to inform
where you make your next move so again
in the chat or in person feel free to
suggest the move and we'll kind of play
it out and see what happens and talk
about why
any suggestions
and also while you're thinking apologies
for my voice I'm kind of on the tail end
of a fever much better but I sound worse
than I am so I apologize if that comes
through on the mic
all right light to move what should we
do to get our ladder mate set up
uh Queen E3 okay I like this a lot we're
gonna attack the king
and force him to go somewhere let's say
I play this move
you
um
okay so this is really important notice
the king is kind of in the way we would
like our ladder to involve the queen and
the Rook so we're just going to move the
king out of the way uh King E7 perfectly
fine
I'll go here to G6
and Adam I'll come back to your comments
after we finish this variation
uh Queen we could go to E6
um what's your idea from there
Rook
so we could do that I think it makes a
little more sense because it looks like
we're kind of already pushing the king
towards this Edge
so we're taking away this row and then
we move the king to take away this row
so I think we should keep up the pattern
and take away this one
so I would probably play Queen to G1 or
to G3 here
and then we just need the Rook somewhere
to deliver checkmate
so how can we get it to our Rook can
call Checkmate
a lot of different options you can just
play some waiting move and the King's
gonna have to move but you can always
switch over to the other side and bring
a Checkmate this way
um had we gone here this is also going
to work right your suggestion
I think it just gets a little muddy if
the the king Comes This Way
it's maybe a little confusing we're
going to get a Checkmate but it's not
exactly a ladder so what you can always
do is you can always reset right if
you're really not sure the position
right even in the starting one we could
just very simply try and set up a ladder
by moving the queen to where it needs to
go next to the Rook so let's say we play
The Rook this way
and then decide to bring it
down this way
and then we just kind of slide our King
out of the way so he's not going to be
causing any problems
we slide Our Queen down and again it
took us a bunch of moves but we're not
worried so much about efficiency here
worried about finding a good Solution
that's going to be very easy and simple
we don't have to think too hard about it
um and to look at Adam's comment here uh
since the queen is back away we can move
the Rook to E8 yeah so this is also
going to be totally fine right the queen
is covering this rank so we can switch
The Rook over to attack this one and
kind of continue from there right so you
could do the way I did it and bring the
Rook down and the queen down and then
kind of ladder your way to the end
but there's a bunch of ways you can do
it as well right we can just slide the
king out of the way and Ladder you some
other way you know we could if we really
wanted to you could ladder this way
this would be a nice checkmate
but the idea is again just slowly taking
away these squares and again here we
notice our King is actually in the way
so we're just going to slowly move them
out of the way
and get a Checkmate right efficiency is
not the the be-all end-all here it's
finding something that you know is going
to work tried and true safe and Simple
Solutions No Stress Chess
now this changes slightly when instead
of a queen in a rook or two queens or
something like that we have just two
Rooks right the pattern is the same but
one key difference is that now we are
very weak to diagonal attacks because we
have no diagonal piece
so we have to be mindful of that and uh
make sure if our work is in danger or
will be that we play accordingly so here
let's start by setting up the same thing
Rook A3
and let's say the king comes towards us
you can immediately just try and set up
the ladder you know just bring the Rooks
to the same side but the Rooks or the
cleaning Rook you can also do it from
opposite sides right there's no threats
so we can just continue to take away one
rung at a time
King to B5
now notice the next rank we would like
to take is the fifth rank because we
already control the fourth with this
Rook so this is the one that needs to
move right if we move this Rook up
we gain the fifth rank but it's not
actually helping us push the king away
because now the king can just come down
and we certainly can't play this move
because now the king will just take us
so whenever you're in this type of
situation with the two Rooks
to me again the no stress answer is to
switch sides so move the Rook that needs
to be the one to take away the next rung
on the ladder as far as it can to the
other side of the board
without getting in its own way right so
I would play Rook to G3
I don't really want to go all the way to
H3 because now these two Rooks are going
to bounce into each other they're not
going to be able to move very smoothly
right we can see that I can take this
one but I I they're just in each other's
way
so I'll go to G3 instead and now we're
just going to continue the ladder all
the way down the board taking away one
wrong at a time
can't do it now because one of our Rooks
is attacked so if we try and finish the
ladder we're going to lose a rook
so better here is to Simply again switch
to the other side as far as you can go
without getting in your own way
again same thing here we would like to
move this Rook down because this one
controls the whole rung but if we do
that they're just going to take it so
we're going to switch all the way over
without getting on our own way
and secure a nice checkmate
so now let's take a practice exam
two Rooks what do you want to try try
and set up your ladder mate with the two
Rooks however you'd like
any suggestions
okay someone is suggesting G5 so do you
want the king or The Rook or sorry the
G5 is there Rook to G5 okay so this is I
think a good move we're cutting off the
king from this whole part of the board
okay let's say I go here how do we get
the other one involved
and again if you're in the live audience
or in the chat feel free to throw out
some suggestions
Rook H7 I love it
uh A7 from the chat also would have
worked
getting to another Edge but either way
we're out of our own Rooks way
in this case even though our Rook is
attacked our King happens to be close
enough we don't have to worry about it
we can just start the ladder all the way
down Rook H4
what should we do now
uh yeah we can do Rook A5 Rook A5 I
think is going to be fine if it's me I'm
probably gonna play uh
yeah I think Rook A5 is fine
the only reason I'm hesitant is because
now this king is going to go this way
but I can always switch the other one
over
and if you switch this one I don't know
that it makes much of a difference
ultimately I'm going to want this one
over here as well so again the nice
thing is there's a whole bunch of ways
to do this same answer Rook A5 Rook B4
and we can again slowly but surely bring
the ladder down until we've cut off
every Escape square and we get a
Checkmate this is the most I think
fundamental type of Checkmate it's one
of the earliest ones you learn but it
teaches us some really important stuff
right
especially about controlling space and
cutting off Escape squares for this King
we're going to take it up a level most
people probably familiar with the ladder
now we're going to do the king and queen
Checkmate again and we're not going to
go through these super super long but
there's a few different ways to do this
one very popular way that I'm not going
to be showing as much today is to use
the queen and king and just kind of
slowly bring them in together and take
away space until you get a Checkmate the
reason I don't like that one as much as
a no stress solution is because it's
really easy to get stalemates when you
have the king and queen both together
right for example let me just kind of
fabricate some nonsense on the board
over here or I get these two pieces
really close
uh this is a stalemate
I actually didn't mean for that to be a
stalemate but I just happened to control
all of these squares
um had I done this
this is a stalemate
because I'm controlling all of these
squares
um something like
let's say something like this this is a
stalemate
right I'm controlling all of these
squares so it's just very dangerous and
very easy to create a stalemate when you
get both of the king and queen involved
too early so feel free to do it it does
work it just you have to be extra
careful of which squares you're cutting
off especially with the queen because
sometimes those long diagonals are
tricky
so this is really another really
important piece of advice that we
actually think I'll touch on in a little
bit is if you're ever in doubt of
calling a stalemate just call check
right if they can't move it's Checkmate
uh it doesn't always work but it does
always prevent stalemate
okay so here's my method for the king
and queen trackmate
um and it's pretty simple first thing
you want to do is you want to put your
queen a nice move away from the
opponent's king what I mean is if the
queen was a knight it would attack this
King this is a really good distance
because we control the diagonal in front
of the king at all of these so we are
again forcing the king to an edge of the
board we are effectively cutting off all
of these parts of the board with our
Queen
and uh we are stopping the king from
moving towards us
if we were too close he could take us
and we would need our King to be close
enough to defend but again that
increases the risk of stalemate
so we're going to move a knight's move
away and most of the time this doesn't
always work but most of the time
wherever your opponent moves you are
going to copy that move so
King to E5
this King moves back one I will move the
same with my queen maintain Knight's
move distance and do the exact same move
if the king moves diagonally away from
me I'm going to move diagonally towards
him if he moves
diagonally down right I'm going to do
that right whatever move the king makes
I just follow it exactly
until the king touches an edge of the
board
because now if the king touches an edge
of the board
and I make that follow move
it's stalemate
this is the one risk of stalemate in
this position in this uh lesson so as
soon as the king touches a corner or an
edge
you stop this Rule and this also works
even if they don't immediately go to a
corner right this isn't stalemate but if
you continue the pattern of following it
will eventually always lead to a
stalemate
but this method always works uh the only
downside is sometimes they'll make a
movie you can't copy so for example in
this position if the king plays to F3 I
can't step onto my own King sometimes I
there would be a position where I would
step off the board to copy the move in
those positions my recommendation is
either to move the queen again to a
different Knights move away
or to just move the king just to the
side just play a waiting move and reset
the situation right and usually then
again they'll make a move and you can
copy it
so that's kind of the only thing that
can happen but again if they make a move
you can't copy you can get a different
Knights move away or you can just wait
with your king
okay once we get the opponent's king to
the edge of the board
now we stop our copying and you do
something really important we want to
keep the king trapped on the edge when
it's a corner we get to pick right
there's two different edges this one and
this one
so we can pick which Edge do you want to
do the seventh rank or the G file which
one should we keep the king stuck on
keep them stuck on the H file so we're
going to take over the G file so what we
need to do is put our Queen somewhere on
the G file
but make sure that the King has at least
one move so is there anywhere we can put
our Queen on the G file
where black will still have at least one
move which is always going to be on this
H file
where can we put our Queen to do that
uh Queen on G6 does not do that because
on G6 we're still cutting off this
Square
so where instead
we can't get to G8
we need yeah G5 or G4 either of these
squares keep the king stuck
but with at least one move
and once you have done this the king
will move and your job is to leave the
queen where she is for the rest of the
game until she calls checkmate
because now she's created a wall that's
keeping the king stuck on the edge of
the board and we are going to bring in
our King to help support the queen so in
this case I would bring the king up this
way kind of perpendicular to the wall
the queen is locking the king down on
and deliver a checkmate it doesn't
matter if our Queen is all the way down
here so uh as a good point of fact even
if my queen was on G1 this king gets all
of these squares that doesn't matter to
me because I just need to bring my King
close enough to support the queen in
getting a checkmate
in this position it is White's moving a
Checkmate in one because anytime you can
put your queen directly in front of an
opponent's king where it's defended by
yours it's trackmate on the edge of the
board
if the king had gone away I would just
follow
until checkmate
again if the King was over here
Checkmate would be here because I am
right in front of the opponent's king
cutting off all of these squares and I'm
defended by my own King
again this will work a hundred percent
of the time all you have to do is make
sure when the king touches the edge you
do not get a stalemate a few examples of
that
in this position
it is white to move do we have any move
to trap this King on a wall
without calling stalemate
Queen where
so Queen F6 is really really funny
because technically it does what it's
supposed to we haven't actually put our
Queen on either of these walls but Queen
F6 is very very good it's actually the
best move I think
if we put our Queen anywhere else right
we can't go to G2 because the king is
there G1 we're behind our King so we're
not actually creating a wall
we can't go on this diagonal to the
seventh rank
and if we go to F7
it's stalemate
so in this type of situation
all you need to do is reset and to do
that I like calling a check so I think
F6 is great the benefit here is we
actually are going to force the king to
stay on the edge but even if we hadn't
even if we just play some other move
we can just reset the situation
and now say okay well I could either
move my king or stand Knight's move away
and we'll just reset until we can do
exactly what we need to
so that's something good to keep in mind
is even if you don't have that perfect
move that's going to lock them on the
edge
just play a move maybe a check to be
sure and reset and you'll be fine
the only thing to be important of is
like you wouldn't hear I would not
recommend playing something like Queen
to H1 or queen to f8 because we don't
want to check on the last rank that's
going to actually give the king more
room to escape
f8 is fine here actually because the
king stays on the wall but we still
don't have a good move to lock him down
right we can't go to any of these
squares because the king will just take
us so we've got to do another move to
reset
something like this
but now again we're great to go
and we can just bring our King in
very casually for a Checkmate when the
king is close enough
it is checkmate
and one more example of that in this
position white to move
what can we do to trap the king
5 check is a great move here much better
than Queen G7 because even though this
trap is looking on the edge once again
whenever the king's Too Close there's
always ideas of stalemate so a check
here is great
now what do you do
uh King D7 works for me
yep F4 perfect
we can just mirror right we can just
mirror the moves
so again the king touches an edge can we
can we trap the King on the edge
we can bring the king in that's going to
be fine my recommendation is again I
think the safest way to avoid stalemates
is to get the queen involved first I
actually again don't like the king being
so close
so yeah we can just do a nice move away
but remember we generally want to stop
that rule when the king touches an edge
because it's going to be a little more
risky I would say here I'm just going to
reset the situation I'm just going to
move my king away because you think he's
too close
gotta play a move okay well I'll go
Knights move away
and now I've got you right where I want
you
a lot of options but I think the
simplest ones are to start by moving a
knight's move away with the queen
mirroring the opponent when possible all
the way to the edge and just playing a
waiting move with your king when not but
again trying to keep the king out of the
way to avoid stalemates once the king
touches an edge of the board we stop
mirroring moves and we find if there is
a way to trap him on the edge to do it
if not just reset play a move and then
trap in the next turn always default to
a check if you're not sure because it's
going to be avoiding stalemates
um
and then just bring the king in once the
king's stuck on the wall
and it should be an easy win
so that's the king and queen Checkmate
again the ideas are the same as the
ladder mate right we are removing
squares from the King slowly enclosing
him towards an edge of the board where
we can deliver a Checkmate it's just a
little more difficult when you don't
have two of those pieces you just have
one
now
we're going to make it even a little
harder
what if we have a king and a rook
instead of a king and a queen
so this one does get harder
my method for this is we're going to do
the same thing we did before first we're
going to make a box I'm going to
actually I'm going to pick a corner
so which corner do we want to push this
King towards
take your pick H1 or h8
it's your favorite Square let's go there
so to push the king to h8 we're going to
need to make a box that cuts the king
off from going this way and from going
this way so we won't don't want the king
to go down or away from h8 so our ideal
square is going to be for The Rook to
cut off those uh I can't do it in one
move because it's on the corner but I'm
going to start with something like Rook
A3
you can also play Rook C1 it's going to
be very similar but yeah Rook A3 and we
are cutting the king off from moving
down the board away from h8
Kate King's going to go as far away from
the square as I can
um and I can't really make any progress
with the Rook so the first thing you
kind of need to do is to get the king
and Rook to where they're defending each
other
um and for sake of argument let's say
the King goes to D4 to stay in the
center
we have made a box
so what we would like to do now we have
cut the king off from going away from
this corner we're directing him right to
h8 is we're going to make this box
smaller when we can
so we kind of have three rules one make
the Box smaller if we can't do that we
put the king in opposition which is
where the kings are looking directly at
each other with one square in between
you can also do this on the diagonal
and if we can't do either of those
things we play a waiting move just move
the king to the side let's see that in
action
so if black plays this move can we make
the Box any smaller towards h8
yeah we can move the Rook one over and
now instead of this being the Box
this is the box right this is where it
was so that red arrow but now we've
taken away one extra row
what if the king had gone here
can we make the Box smaller
we cannot right if we tried to take away
this row we would get taken so the next
question can we put the king in
opposition
so you can triangulate that's going to
be a little better
um but for no stress stress for
Simplicity I'm just going to say put the
king in opposition I think the reason
you don't want to do that is because
you're foreseeing what happens here
King's going to go to the side can we
make the Box smaller
we're just going to move the Rook up and
take one more row away
and now we get this position which I
think you were hoping to avoid
can we make the Box any smaller here
we cannot right this does not make the
Box smaller even though it looks like it
does because if we play here
we actually don't cut off this row
we open up this whole side of the board
so now the king can go this way away
from our Square
so instead
instead of playing here we can't make
the Box smaller we can't put our King in
opposition because they're already in
opposition so what I would do here is
just play a waiting move play your king
to the side make sure to keep defending
the Rook right don't wait this way
that's not so good just wait over here
and wherever this black king moves we're
going to have those same three questions
if the King goes here can we make the
Box smaller
yes
if the King goes uh here oops
everything goes here we can't make the
Box smaller
but we can put the king in opposition
and if the King goes here we can make
the Box smaller
so those are the questions you ask and
we can do this all the way down to the
edge of the board
we can make the Box smaller we can make
the Box smaller
we can't make the Box smaller right if
we call a check with the Rook we make it
bigger so we bring the king closer in
this case it is opposition right we can
bring the king to opposition it's just
diagonal this time
we can't make the Box smaller so we put
the king in opposition
King in opposition
can we make the Box smaller yes
can we make the Box smaller no can we
put the king in opposition no it's
already in opposition so we play a
waiting move
but eventually as you see we will force
our way to the end of the board with
these questions
and once the king gets to our kind of
edge or corner there's re the nice thing
about this is there's really I think
only one way to get stalemate and it's
to do this all the way to the end
um we can't make the Box smaller so we
go here and actually let me improve
black splay I'm going to put him here
first
it's something like this
so the problem is here yeah if you play
King to h8 we do have Checkmate here
but if I don't see it if I keep asking
these questions all the way down I'm
going to say can I make the Box smaller
and I'll get a stalemate so I think
literally this is the only position
where it's going to be stalemate if if
I'm wrong feel free to correct the
internet but if you have the Rook
keeping the king locked in again your
king can be on any of these squares
defending the Rook but I think as long
as you don't literally just do this
you're fine
and now there's a few different ways to
get a Checkmate here once you get them
to this corner my recommendation is
again once they're on the edge and in
the corner uh if your king is
controlling these squares and they're in
the corner we can just play checkmate
if the timing has worked out differently
something like this
where again here I could have just
played checkmate
but something like this now I can't play
Checkmate oops because if I try that
they'll just take
if I just wait they just wait too
so this doesn't make any progress
so what I would recommend here
there's two ways to I mean there's a lot
but there's two ways I would recommend
one is to just triangulate with the king
so we're going to take three turns to do
what black skin is going to do in two
turns
kind of a sneaky way to win back
opposition and force a checkmate
easier is we're just going to play a
waiting move with the Rook
you can move it anywhere on this file if
we move it this way
uh then the king gets more Escape
so we're just going to move it back you
can go as far as you want or as few as
you want and it forces the king in the
corner and then we get a nice simple
checkmate
so that's my method for the king and
Rook Checkmate we first we have to build
the box so we do that by identifying
which corner we want to lock the king
down on and get our King and Rook
connected
then whenever black makes a move we ask
the questions
can we make the Box smaller if so yes
if not
right I this doesn't make it smaller
because you just go this way and this is
not a good move if not can I put the
king in opposition if so do it
and if I don't have either of those
options
I can't make the Box smaller I can't put
the king in opposition because they're
already there just play a waiting move
and reset the situation and you'll be
able to do one of those three things
keep pushing towards the edge of the
board and eventually you will win with
this kind of a nice idea
either if the timing works out you can
just get a Checkmate if not you can
triangulate or you can just drop the
Rook back and deliver a checkmate
okay
so that's the king and Rook so we've
done the ladder mate which is the most
simple right forcing squares by taking
one row at a time and it's easier
because we have multiple pieces to work
with
then we did the king and and we did that
with the queen and Rook versus the two
Rooks then we did the king and queen
Checkmate and the queen can just kind of
mirror the king's movements uh from a
night's move away all the way down to
the edge of the board stopping at the
edge locking the king away making sure
he has a stalemate escape and then
bringing our King in and now with the
King Rook we set up a box well we pick a
corner set up a box towards that corner
and then we asked for three questions
every move can I make the Box smaller if
not can I put the king in opposition if
not I'll play a waiting move and you get
to that ending and decide if you can
just win or if you need to drop the Rook
back to win
now a lot of people know those
checkmates not as many know the two
Bishops checkmate which I think is a
shame because it's not really that hard
if you have some really solid
understanding but it's very different
right we can't just do the latter method
because for example say I try and cut
off these rows or these diagonals one at
a time right what's going to happen even
if my Bishops are like really far away
from this King
say I set them up really nicely in the
edge I mean this is actually
unproductive because one I'm going to
hit the edge of the board but even if I
wasn't
every time I move the bishop I actually
give an escape square away
so this works very differently than
normal
here is my method for if you have two
Bishops now they have to be opposite
colors right if you have two of the same
colored you could actually have
however many squares there are 32 light
squared Bishops and or dark squared
Bishops and it would be unable to get a
Checkmate right because this king would
just walk on all the other colored
squares so they have to be the two
different colors but if you have those
here is my method for how to get a
Checkmate the first thing you want to do
is control the center
so these four Center squares we're going
to control it and you can
I think always do that in two moves now
that will maybe sometimes change based
on your king position but generally
speaking you should be able to do that
very simply so in this position we can
control the center with something like
Bishop to B2
the king's got to move
and Bishop to G2 and notice how our two
Bishops have controlled all four Center
squares forcing the king out of the way
now that those four are under our
control the next step is to move the
king or sorry to move the Bishops into
the center
so here you want to do it places where
they're not going to be attacked so I
can't move either Bishop to D5 or to E5
but I can play Bishop to D4
because again notice with my Bishop on
G2 I can't be approached and this bishop
also cuts off the king approaching me
this way
and now with two Bishops in the center
I've set up these arrows to get a better
idea of what's going on notice that
we've actually created a box it's just
diagonal rather than sideways more like
a diamond I guess so the Bishops want a
diamond
um
don't read into that
but notice that when they're sitting
next to each other the king actually has
no way to approach them or to escape no
matter how far away he gets right these
Bishops are always cutting off all the
escapes as long as they stay where they
are
they also don't have any way to push
them further away though so now we need
to bring the king in
and you can go to either side
um but we're going to bring our King
forward so just right next to the two
Bishops to support them
and I'm just having black move back and
forth here because if they go backwards
there's obviously a chance for you to
continue to just close the Box smaller
so this is the most challenging way for
black to play
and once we get our King close enough
we can actually start to
uh
close this diamond even more so what you
want to look for
and I'll take away some of these arrows
so it's maybe a little easier to see the
actual board
but what you want to look for
sorry
is
there we go
is when your king steps forward is their
King closer to you or farther away if
their King is closer so if they just
moved closer then we can actually bring
our other Bishop up
and we make the diamond a little smaller
wherever the king moves we're going to
be able to move our second Bishop in and
again shrink down this diamond
if the king is uh farther away which
we'll actually see in a moment
in this example we move our King forward
and now our opponent moves the king away
from us the problem here is if we try
this same technique
we left open this Escape Square
and now you're in a different diamond
So to avoid this you can either just
move the king up and that will work but
easier is just when you notice this
happening we're going to do that same
triangulation as we did before
so here instead of immediately going to
the square I'm just going to step to the
side
and come back to meet you right now
you're closer to me than over here which
means I can safely move this bishop up
and once again I cut off all of your
escapes you were stuck in this diamond
and now you're stuck actually on the
edge of the board
with the two Bishops trapping you on the
edge of the board the king only has two
squares
so notice uh and I'm going to switch to
a slightly different variation of it
notice the king only has these two
squares
what we're going to do is we are slowly
going to shift you to one of these two
corners in this case you're closer to
this one so I'm going to shift you over
to the A8 corner
but you can do it either way it doesn't
make a difference
and what we need to do is we need our
King to cover one of the holes that the
other Bishop creates so let's figure out
what needs to happen here right now this
king's two squares are C8 and d8 in
order to push you this way
we need to take away the ability to go
to d8
but simultaneously open up the ability
to go to B8
both of those are dark squares so our
dark squared Bishop is the one that has
to move it has to give up control of
this square and take control of this
Square
and here's how you're going to do it our
King needs to cover this hole that's
going to be weakened by the bishop
so we're going to rotate our King around
to that side
and this is going to be the same thing
right we want the king to be approaching
us if the king does is not approaching
us or if the timing has worked out
poorly we can triangulate again as
necessary by wasting a move but
eventually the king will be forced to
approach
and now notice how our King has covered
this Square
and our Bishop covers this one
so the king cannot make forward progress
we can now safely switch Bishops this
bishop will release control of this
Square
and gain control of this one
and we are slowly pushing the king over
we're going to see that happen again in
just a moment the king moves here
and now because our King is just right
in front we can actually just
immediately shift control we give up
control of A8 and gain control of C8
and in this position the only thing you
have to watch out for is stalemate
because if I bring the bishop back
then this is a stalemate because I've
taken away all the squares so in a
position like this I just need to lose a
move I want the Bishops to control these
same n diagonals but I don't really care
about these ones because that's not
where I'm making the square so I can
bring the bishop anywhere on this
diagonal that I want
I wouldn't move it closer because that's
probably going to make it a little more
complicated but I would just Retreat one
of these Bishops can be as far or short
as you want
and then we're going to finish this game
with two checks
check
mates
a lot went into that but I don't think
it's as complex as it seems so let's do
it again from out to totally random
position
uh first thing we do is we control these
four Center squares
so we can do it in a lot of different
ways let's just do it like this bishop
to G2
controlling these two squares
Bishop here to B6 or I'm sorry that only
controls one let's play here instead
controlling these two Center squares
the king moves and he can move in two
directions this way or this way
and either way we can set up a diamond
right so if he goes this way
I'm going to set up a diamond
this way blocking him onto this triangle
of the board
I'll do that by doing something like
Bishop to D5 because again I know he
can't approach me
and the King can only go back and forth
or go back farther towards the wall and
we're happy either way
so all I need to do is bring my king
closer
this King has approached mine so because
it's approached the timing has worked
out I can just move this bishop in where
it's defended
all these squares are controlled forcing
this King to move backwards
and I can just rebuild the triangle in
this case I'm going to triangulate a
little bit with black
just to say that or actually no I don't
want to do that
um
I want to be in this position
because now the King has moved away from
me
and there's a lot of ways to deal with
this I would say the simplest is just to
back off and triangulate right
so we're just wasting a turn by moving
three times when this king is only
moving twice and once it has again
approached us we take away this Square
force it to the edge of the board
and now the king only has two squares so
we get to pick a side we want to push it
towards
let's go towards A1 in this case
so to do that I'm going to bring my king
over to that side
in this case the timing is not going to
work out perfectly because if I go to C3
the king will run away so I'm going to
waste a move here C4 and then C3
now that the king is approached
my king is covering this square that my
Bishop was holding on to so I will now
let my Bishop let go of C1 and control
E1 instead
I force the king to move
and I can do the same uh right here I
can take away the square as well
and we are slowly forcing this King over
to the edge
now I want to be a little careful
because I don't really want this King to
step off uh it doesn't really matter but
I'm going to control all of these
squares to keep the king from stepping
onto a different Edge
and now I can just bring the Bishops up
with check
I'm going to have a nice and easy
checkmate
had I let the king Escape it's not the
end of the world so say I played
something like this
now the king's just on a different Edge
but I can kind of reset the situation as
I need to my King Controls these squares
and I don't want the king to run away
so I just need to cut off this Square
how do I do that with this bishop I can
go here or here let's just go here
and now uh I don't want to get a
stalemate
so I need to be very careful with where
I put my pieces but
um
let's go hmm
a few different options
I think the simplest here is probably
just to move my king a little more
Central
and again it can get a little confusing
if you need to take a few moves and
reset that's also totally fine
but again something like this
I am in full control
and I can just when the timing is right
bring the Bishops out with check
I can't play it now because it will be a
stalemate so I just waste a move and the
following will be a check mate
okay so that's the two Bishops mate so
now I've done the ladder mate
I apologize again for my voice going a
little bit we've done the ladder mate
we've done the king and queen Checkmate
the king and rook and now the two
Bishops
and there are two more then I'm going to
give you some advice on I'm not going to
give you a full road map but I'm going
to give you some really good practical
advice
first one is if you have a king and a
queen and you're going against an
opponent with a bishop
this could seem a lot more challenging
but actually in some really weird ways I
think this is almost easier than just a
king and a queen versus a king
and I say that because there's a lot
fewer stalemating chances
the very easy way to mitigate the power
of an opponent's Bishop when they just
have one
this is very apparent in this end game
but also just in general it's a good
strategy
is to put your pieces on a color that
this bishop can't affect
so my opponent here has a light squared
Bishop
if I put my king and queen on dark
squares that Bishop actually can't
affect me at all and I'm going to do the
same things as before because they have
a bishop I do want my king to help
support my queen to be a little safer
but I'm just going to try and force this
King towards the edge
excuse me if at any point this piece
moves too far away from the king I can
look out for opportunities to get a fork
or a double attack so
uh for example if this bishop moves
somewhere like over here
I can already look and see do I have any
way to just win this piece
I do
check
and now
this is converted into a king and queen
end game we know how to do that
so if you can ever win the piece just do
that
um
if there's not like in this position I
don't see an obvious way to Fork this
King and Bishop and even if I could
attack it maybe the king can go defend
so I'm just going to continue to move my
pieces closer to my opponent's king and
force it to an edge while staying on the
other colored squares than their Bishop
is so something like Queen E5
between C5
slowly moving my way in and there's just
not really much my opponent can do as
long as my king and queen stay defending
each other
or rather the king defending the queen
and they stay on the color square that
this Fisher can't affect I'm really in
no danger at all
in this type of position I can play a
lot of moves I can try and trap the King
on the edge I can just move my King
around on these dark squares to get
closer
but eventually you notice that this
bishoping on the board doesn't even
matter
even if it goes somewhere very silly I
can just get a Checkmate and this bishop
really stood no chance so if you
remember that one thing just staying
away from uh the color that that Bishop
can attack then you're totally totally
safe again not a foolproof game plan to
win it but just very practical I think
helpful advice
the last one I want to talk about here
is if you have a queen versus a knight
and this is actually a lot harder than
the queen versus a bishop and I think
it's for a few reasons one because the
Knight can go to any color
uh we can't just have that very nice
simple rule
also the knights movement is less
intuitive than the bishop so it's easier
to fall into traps right like already in
this position if I'm not careful I can
lose my queen it's very easy
so I don't have a foolproof method for
you of winning this game uh I and I
don't feel confident enough to teach it
in that way I played against stockfish
earlier to make sure I could even do it
this was that game
I try to approach slowly but surely
bring my pieces as close as I could and
forcing the king to the edge
being very careful trying not to get
forked and I kind of started repeating a
little bit
um I got checked I I so again was making
very slow progress but it didn't super
feel like it and this king is kind of
spinning around
eventually I was able to find a way to
win
by getting cut my king and queen close
enough and separating my opponent's
Knight but it was very tough
so I don't feel confident enough to
teach you the foolproof method but what
I will say is here are some practical
advice
uh the squares that are away from a
knight are not equally dangerous
so the first thing to notice is the
color square of the night is on
because a knight can make a move to
attack the same color Square you're on
in its move so right right now this
Knight is on a light Square
in one move it can attack my king
because they can move to a dark square
that calls check
so being on the same color as a knight
means it can move to attack you there is
no move this Knight can make to attack
my queen because it is on a different
color Square it would take at least two
moves
uh the other thing to note
so that's the first one is this the most
safe method
is to always have your king and queen on
different colored squares
because if one of them is on a light
square and one of them is on a dark
square at all times the Knight Will
Never Fork them it will attack one but
it will never be able to attack both so
as a practical piece of advice
just keeping these pieces on different
colored squares means you will never
risk a night Fork you don't have to
think about anything else right I can
play this move I can play this move I
can put my queen on any dark Square on
the board uh while I can't just let her
be taken but anyone that's not at risk
and uh I'm not going to get forked so
that's really useful
um the other thing
is specifically with knights they have
some squares it kind of ignore the
kings in the position and I'm not going
to take this Knight I want to show the
way it can move with some squares
if you have a piece that is four squares
away from a knight so if you know the
night's here and there there's two
squares in between is a better way to
say it uh this is the kind of best place
you can be it's going to be very hard
for that Knight to attack you it's going
to take multiple moves for example if I
don't move this queen I'm just going to
move the king back and forth
uh
let's see how many it takes to get the
knights so here and then two so it takes
two full moves from the night to
actually attack my queen
um
let's compare something else if the
queen is right next to the Knight it's
also going to be two moves before it can
attack me
here and here
and again notice how that's uh the queen
is on a dark Square the knights on a
light Square so we already know it's at
least two
another really important example
is when they're on the same color but
they're diagonal with one square in
between this is kind of an obnoxious one
for the night because now wherever it
moves it's either
gonna have those two in between so it's
three here right one two three something
like that or
it could move next to me
and then move out and something like
this but it's going to take three full
moves so staying diagonally away from a
knight with one square in between kind
of diagonal opposition almost if you
will is very useful so just keep some of
those things in mind keep your king and
queen on different colored squares
uh
and if you can stay on the opposite
color as the Knight it can't affect you
in the next turn right next to it is a
great example or uh this kind of two
squares in between but if you're going
to be on the same color and you can be
in diagonal opposition with it it's
going to take it at least three turns to
hit you very very valuable stuff
practically try and keep those things in
mind and try and force the king to an
edge separate it from the Knight if
possible because if you can get that
piece off the board for free it's just a
king and queen end game and we just
talked about how to do that
that is all the time we have for tonight
but hopefully this kind of practical end
game advice has been helpful and uh if
so I'm really glad it was hope to see
you again please stick around because
we're going to have our grandmaster's
choice lecture with women's Grandmaster
uh tatev abrahamian so please stick
around should be awesome and I'll see
y'all later
[Music]